My name is Greg Sands. I'm a partner at Sutter Hill Ventures
and was a graduate of the GSB class of 1994. And I have with
me on the panel two CEO's of wonderful entrepreneurial
companies. I'll let them introduce themselves, but they've
got great stories to tell and I think also a lot of
information to share about thinking about when venture
capital makes sense, when venture capital doesn't make
sense, the process of evolving and growing a business, as
well as the process of raising money and what are some of
the ways that you make sure that you tee yourself up for
success when you're in that environment.
So, let me introduce Matthew Monahan who's the CEO of
Inflection which is a leading people search company that he'
ll describe in a bit more detail, and Terry Austin who's the
CEO of Guardian Analytics which is a anti - fraud solution
for the online banking industry. I happen to be a board
member at both companies, but they're the best two companies
you're likely to find and I'm thrilled to be involved with
them both. I think it's also helpful that one is more
consumer internet based and one is enterprise focus based.
So Matthew, do you want to talk first?
Sure.
Just tell them a little bit about the company and about
yourself so that the audience has a little bit of context?
Yeah. So, I sold a business prior to this. It was a consumer
based eBooks business that was only about five people when
we sold it and then moved into Inflection. This was in 2006.
And so, I started it with my brother. He was at Harvard
doing this from his dorm room.
And essentially, the thesis is that a lot of the public
record systems moving online right now and there's a ton of
data being digitized and moving onto the internet that hasn'
t been affectively organized. And so, we saw an opportunity
here to build a platform to not only bring the data in, but
then also package it for consumers through a variety of
channels whether it's the search engines, and the social
networks, and so forth.
So today, we're up to about 100 employees. We have two main
brands - the first is called archives.com which is a family
tree, family history website that allows you to search your
ancestors. And the second is called PeopleSmart.com which is
a search engine for people. And the main goal there is, "How
do you solve people search in a privacy friendly way?" And
then we have a bunch of other vertical brands that we are
adding data and rolling out including identity protection,
employment screening.
We raised money in the middle of 2010, so it took us about 3
1/2 years before we decided to raise our series A deal. And
so, up until that point we bootstrapped the company. It's
been profitable since we started which is something that we'
re very focused on and very proud of. And it's a phenomenal
team of a bunch of great people. And we're just over here on
[inaudible]
Great Matthew, great background. And there's a whole bunch
there that I think is interesting and are great lessons in
that process about starting a business, evolving a business,
coming up with the strategic framework for what's really a
good business and a defensible business that we can get into
over time as well.
So Terry, do you want to do the same thing?
Sure.
Talk a little bit about the company and about yourself so
people have some broad context?
Sure. Absolutely. I'm Terry Osmond, CEO of Guardian
Analytics. I've been CEO for two years. The company's been
around for about 5 1/2 - almost six years. So, I joined
later. I joined after the company had done kind of a seed
followed by an "A" round. Though we've labeled it
differently I'll just use that.
And the company had a version 1 product and they had about
six or seven customers using the product. So, there were
certain prove points that had been established and I'd been
there for about two years and did a couple of transitions of
the company. We're now on version 4 of the product. So, we'
ve introduced some pretty significant revs. And the most
recent one was to move to a Sass architecture to deliver
this product in a much more scalable and fast growing
manner.
So, the essential solution is fraud prevention and online
banking as Greg mentioned. We solve a really massive, and
growing, and vexing issue. Internet banking's been around
for a long time. It's evolved quite a bit. There's a new
generation of internet banking that's upon us with mobile
banking, with all sorts of different paying mechanisms being
integrated into the online banking system. And one of the
things that doesn't get talked about much is that fraud has
grown and almost outpaced the innovation of online banking
itself.
And the protections that have been in place to date have not
really been effective to stop online fraud. It keeps getting
bigger. More money gets stolen. The criminals are more
embolden than ever and there's very little repercussion for
the criminal that gets caught. They tend to be overseas.
There's not much jurisdiction that can affect them. They
just move on to the next victim. And the traditional
techniques of either trying to protect your computer or
mobile device with anti - virus protection or anti - malware
protection have failed. It's a finger in the tyke against a
tsunami that's hitting them with malware provocation. And
authentication techniques are really an attempt to put a
really strong lock on the door. Any of the most
sophisticated multi - factor authentication techniques have
also failed because they made the assumption that once
somebody successful logs in and passes whatever test you
give them, then you can trust them.
And the fact is that all of the malware that's loaded on all
these machines and mobile devices is designed to defeat
authentication. And once it's defeated and the criminals' in
they can do all sorts of things to steal money and extract
value out of the financial system.
So, we take a radically different approach to the problem.
We assume that the end point's compromised and that
authentication's defeated and we use all of the information
that a user creates on the interaction with the online
banking system to create a very specific, individualized
behavioral profile of that user. And from that we can
actually very precisely and very accurately detect when
someone's logging in that's not a legitimate user. And we're
now deployed at about 45 banks and credit unions throughout
the country using the system we're targeting to sort of long
tail the banking industry. There are about 17,000 financial
institutions that are a target market in the U.S. And that's
a kind of essential solution.
Okay. So, what I'd love to do is to frame a little bit how I
think about entrepreneurial companies, and what I look for,
and what's interesting to me. But I don't actually want the
whole discussion to be about fundraising and about venture
capital because a big part of that story is really about
identifying good businesses and good people.
And so, you know, to me the kernels in there that are
interesting is focusing on partly how I'm evaluating, you
know, our great people, great CEO's and entrepreneurs so
that you can chart your course in an appropriate way and
partly what are really good businesses. And I think in both
cases there are some really interesting anecdotes about
transitioning the business to be a better business. And
that's what I'm most interested in. But there is a little
bit of framework over that and we'll sort of bounce back and
forth with I think a couple of these factors.
So, at Sutter Hill Ventures we've been in the venture
capital business in Silicon Valley for 48 years. You know,
by virtue of doing that I think we are not - and don't try
to specifically be - sector specialists in the sense that I'
m a Sass guy, or I'm a consumer internet guy, or the like. I
think my mandate is basically anything that touches software
and comes from software and the like, you know, you have to
evolve with the times. And you ultimately do that by:
Figuring out how to be in business with great people.
How to get into really good businesses.
And the way I like to say that is some of my partners will
say, "So, we're micro - ergonomic." Meaning, you know, not
thematic, right? You can think about, you know, there are
firms that are
[inaudible] firms that are consumer only firms just like you
look at the marketing of mutual funds and some will say, "
Hey, we're the science and technology team." What we want to
be is the really good business with really great readers.
And you do that by looking - from my perspective - at the
company's unit analysis, not the sector. Right?
So, I know people will come in and say, "Man! I've really
got to be in the
[inaudible] search business. I'm going to go and interview
six companies." When people search business I'm going to
figure out which of those is the best because I've already
determined that it's a sector that I want to be in. There
are people that do it - it's not what I do. If you try to
initiate that conversation at my partnership you get thrown
out of the room.
And so, people would say, you know, "Let's talk about a
company", right? I mean, you can go meet with six companies.
Talk about one that you think is a good example. It's a
little bit like thinking of it as the case study method of,
you know, studying here at the GSB. But those basically do
come down to, you know, fundamental economics of the
business
[inaudible]. Are you in a growing sector? Is there an
incumbent leader that you're displacing? Are you
evangelizing a new market? Do you have the meek and
proprietary technology or are there business advantages
that, you know, that you either have or are pretty clear
that you can build over time. And you know, the fundamental
framework for evaluating that is risk and reward.
And so, lots of people come and say, "Hey, I'm building this
marketplace and you know, once I have the buyers and sellers
I'll have this great defensible advantage." But of course,
various entry before you have them are various entry for you
too, right? So you know, one of my partners always says, "
That's great. That's a ham and eggs business model. If I had
ham and if I had eggs I'd have ham and eggs. But you start
out with neither and it really doesn't do you a whole lot of
good."
You know, the people side of it is really very nuanced,
right? We're all just making our own judgments and our own
assessments for, you know, some things that are general and
some things that are specific to the opportunity. And I
think the right place to start when I think about it is that
in my partnership the single greatest compliment that you
can give someone is that they're intellectually honest, you
know? And both of these guys met that task.
The question is are you evaluating data? And are you living
by the data? And are you learning every day? And do you have
a strategy? And is it working? Are you unafraid to call it
and to change? And you know, if somebody can do that that's
the fundamental process. Another way of saying it is
starting a company is a great truth telling device, right?
You know, the market doesn't lie and if it doesn't like what
you're doing you've got to do something different. And you
know, there are plenty of people out there who either only
want to hear good news, only want to raise the next round so
that they can keep running the company. And so, I think
that's just, you know, the basic piece.
It's also the case that leadership matters, right? You see
it in, you know, all kinds of circumstances, but ultimately
entrepreneurial companies should not succeed. And the only
way that they succeed is by small bands of great people
taking on giants and accomplishing things that shouldn't be
able to be done. And in order to do that you have to
galvanize resources that you don't deserve of better quality
people than ought to be, you know, drawn into these small
companies, more capital and resources than, you now, a
traditional financial investor would be willing to provide,
partners in distribution channels where people are taking
big bets on you that they shouldn't in some logical
construct.
And so, I think that notice when it says, "Intellectual
honesty, leadership to galvanize and draw those kind of
resources, enough self confidence and humility to be willing
to consistently hire people who are better than you are in a
specific domain." And then there are some really complicated
pieces about, "How do you hire someone in a domain that you
don't know that well?"
And the easy way I say that is I think for a lot of people
coming out of business school
[inaudible] "I got to hire a CEO, hire a VP of Marketing,
hire a product manager" is a relatively straight forward
thing to do. Hiring a VP of Engineering when you're not an
engineer - that's hard, right? Hiring a VP of Sales actually
when you don't have sales experience yourself - really hard
cause sales people know how to sell.
And it's really hard. And to me those are the two biggest
challenges. And most people if they're going to become CEO's
at some point have to go from being really knowledgeable in
a function to being a general manager managing functions
where they don't know as much as the people that they're
hiring and are working for.
And so, that judgment that says, "Boy, this is someone that
can figure that out, who knows what they know, knows what
they don't know, is learning quickly enough the stuff that
they don't know." And you know, that to me is sort of the
central framework.
So you know, I think with that I'd actually like to turn to
Matthew. And I'll give a little bit about what I saw in the
business when I saw him, but then ask him to tell the story
of the beginning and the evolution of that business.
So first, I'll say I was totally impressed with Matthew the
minute I met him. And so, as you can see these guys are
different ages, they've got different backgrounds.
[Informal Talk]
I actually try and look through someone's age, or exact
experience, and the like when I'm trying to infer qualities
and capabilities. And I think some of the things that I
referenced were just crystal clear in Matthew, right?
Dedication to the company and to the task., commitment to
being that driven, running more experience and learning
faster - including failing faster - than anybody else, had
already demonstrated in spite of being a relatively young
CEO that he'd been able to hire people more experienced in
certain disciplines and be able to attract talent seeing as
that's always one of the challenges for a relatively young
CEO, and an incredible sense of self knowledge, and
humility, and willingness to learn from all places, right?
Not that I or the other investors are, you know,
pontificating from on high. We're one upon many. He's out
talking to business partners and talking to other CEO's, and
just learning, and picking it up. So, if there were ever a
time where you said, "This is a guy who is great and getting
better every day", you know, this is the guy.
The other thing that I think is interesting and points out
just a little bit about the venture process is that there
were a couple of things that gave me a little bit of insight
into the business, right? So, one of which was I had just
done a big genealogy project. So, I had some personal
knowledge of the space.
The second is that I had done a bunch of work in
monetization, and lead generation, and ad targeting. And
while they're using that technology stack for a very
different purpose, it was a technology stack that I was
relatively familiar with.
So, I think for anybody that you're trying to pitch the
business to - they're having one or two of those access
points that take things that might be a little mysterious
and make them really easily understandable is a big
difference.
So, that was my orientation coming into the business. Now,
Matthew can tell you how the business started, how he
actually grew it to that point, and some of the decisions
they made along the way.
Cool. Thank you for the kind words. So, when we started the
business we had about $75,000 - 100,000 in seed capital from
the proceeds of the last business. So, that's some of the
context on self - funding it. But we were able to do that
and self - fund that business from there over the few years.
One of the key things that I went into at Silicon Valley - I
moved out here in early 2007. I had very strong skepticism
of VC's and I actually would encourage you all to have
strong skepticism of the VC's - except for Greg. No. But in
all seriousness I think that, you know, you hear a lot of
horror stories. You hear a lot of stories of entrepreneurs
saying, "Hey, you know, don't raise money if you don't have
to", or "I got booted from my company", or something like
that.
And so, I came in with my guards up. I was very fearful of
even going down that path or that process. And we had a
business model where if you could figure out how to make $1.
10 for every dollar that you invested for promoting the
products that you could scale it relatively well. And I also
had the distinct advantage that I had a co - founder that
between us we kind of knew how to build the site, put the
Ecommerce engine together, and do the marketing without
needing too much other talent. Although, you know,
Engineering talent was the first folks to hire.
So, I would echo from a entrepreneur perspective what Greg
was saying about the people mattering the most. I think its
mattered the most to us in terms of the team that we brought
on board and it's been a huge factor consideration in terms
of how we selected the VC's - Greg and then also Josh from
Matrix Partners.
And so, my personal philosophy is just kind of copy what
other people figured out. So, on a hiring front we do -
smart and gets things done. Those are kind of the two
criteria in terms of how we think about position. Part of
getting things done means that they fit in culturally. And
so, you know, no asshole rule. We want to make sure that
people are, you know, going to fit into the company and do
well. But that formula - Google's repeated it. There's been
a lot of engineering blogs that have talked about that -
smart and gets things done.
And then on the partner side - which we consider our
investors to be partners - it's Warren Buffet's model which
is, "People that you know, people that you like and people
that you trust". And I just think that's the best wisdom I'
ve been able to find on how to select partners is you've got
to get to know them, you've got to like them - and Greg's a
very likable guy - and you've got to trust them. And I think
integrity was always very critical to us in terms of
selecting an investment partner partly because we were a
little bit skeptical of bringing on money as entrepreneurs.
So, how we went down the process was we basically friended a
venture capitalist...
Actually, back up about two years...
Sure.
cause I think the main part of the interesting thing that I
want these guys to hear is how did you go for three years
without raising any money...
Yeah.
cause I think that's actually a big part of it too.
So in 2007, the gentleman that had purchased our prior
business, he was in North Carolina and he made an
introduction to his roommate back from Harvard Business
School. And one of the recurring things - I didn't go to
business school. I actually dropped out of undergrad. But
one of the things that has happened since I've been kind of
trying to scale the organization and everything else is
those of you that are in business school - the connections
that you guys are getting cannot be underestimated. Do not
underestimate them. Hugely important in so many ways. I can'
t reinforce that enough.
Be nice to everybody.
And on that front - just a side tangent here - but if you're
not an engineer and you need to hire an engineer, or you're
not a salesperson and you need to hire a VP of Sales, I
think part of the way to solve that is through weak ties.
And there's been a lot of studies that, you know, the more
weak ties that you have, the more successful you will
become. And I think having a lot of weak ties with people in
diverse interest groups which business school is a great
breeding ground for that in many ways in terms of university
environment. You can build a lot of those weak ties and you
never know when those phone calls or those contacts are
going to be useful.
But that aside, the first thing I did when I started the
business was I had a mentor that had kind of introduced me
to internet marketing long ago, and then the gentleman who
had bought our prior business - we brought them in as
advisors. And they had some stock in the company, but they
didn't have any board seats. We didn't have a board. There
was none of that. But they kind of serviced us as kind of a
functional board if you will because we didn't have a formal
kind of people who were giving us feedback, and supervising
us as the entrepreneurs and as the co - founders.
And that worked extremely well. I think that, you know,
getting advisors as people you trust - whether it's a
professor, whether it's a friend, whatever - but getting
people that you respect and feel are knowledgeable in
certain areas to advise you on the business is really
important. And they introduced us to a gentleman by the name
of Jason Green who is a venture capitalist over at Emergence
Capital. And Jason and Rick - one of our advisors - had been
roommates.
Jason we purely met from a, "Hey, this is an entrepreneur."
"Hey, this is a guy I trust. You guys should get to know
each other because you're new to the Bay area." And what
Jason did was he invited me to one of the D.C. events that
Emergence Capital puts on where, you know, you have this big
atrium and all these people, you know, cocktails, and food,
and so forth. And it was there that we met our first
executive.
And so, this was the path that we took, but basically it was
there that I met a gentleman by the name of John
[inaudible] who would run Match.com from '97 - 2000. He had
a very lustrous career in internet, helped a few companies
go public.
And we basically maintained very low salaries. For the first
I think nine months we didn't really make anything and then
after that it was like $30,000 a year. We were putting all
of the money into executive hiring. And John was one of the
first executives we brought on board that also brought
another executive who is named Donald Lanneret. And those
guys made a humongous impact on our business because what
they did is they took a lot of the business development,
they took a lot of the operations completely out of our
mindshare - our being Brian and I - so we could focus on the
products and marketing.
So, for us getting the products and marketing nailed really
is all that mattered. And I think one of the most important
lessons that I've learned in terms of that experience is
anything you can do to reduce your plate and continue to
focus on the few things that you really have to get done for
everything else to develop, take advantage of those
opportunities and don't underestimate them. Try not to do
everything. As an entrepreneur you want to do everything.
Try not to do everything. Try to make sure that you're
nailing the really important stuff.
And you know, if I draw that theme from a couple of other
examples that I've seen and the thing that I think Matthew
and Brian did so well is think of themselves out of the gate
as founder and VP of X, right?
So, the way entrepreneurial companies succeed and especially
really don't require a ton of capital is one as much,
probably more focused on getting stuff done than on being
smart. And even when there is a team of founders, there is
no room for overhead, right? So you know, picking out those
two most important things and saying, "They're too important
for them to be done by anybody but the founders" .
So, I can think of another example - Merced Systems - where
I'm involved. Basically one of them said, "I got product"
and the other said, "I got sales". And it turned out he'd
never really sold anything before, but he was really, really
good at it.
And for the first two years they just did it, right? They
did the first 10 sales by himself. So, you want to be
focused enough so that you develop the
[inaudible] and hire around it. But you've just got to get
in and do it, you know, and get stuff done. And these guys
have done an exceptional job at what they're doing.
Yeah. So, now I'm going to go back to the capital part, and
close the loop, and say a few nice things about VC's because
I started on the negative side. What we did is we actually
found that, "Hey, this introduction from Jason resulted in
an executive hire. We need more help hiring. We need more
help understanding the business."
And so, we started developing relationships with a lot of
different venture capitalists in Silicon Valley. I would say
that venture capitalists are kind of like the nodes of
activity that are happening in a lot of the different
industries and companies. They have amazing visibility into,
"What are the decisions getting made at the leadership
level?", "What are the board meetings looking like?", and so
forth.
And so, as an entrepreneur you can consume a lot of
information that's really valuable all entirely for free
over lunches, coffees, drinks, whatever, with a wide variety
of folks. And most venture capitalists when approached will
definitely sit down and meet with you.
And so, the key thing on developing relationships on that
front that I learned was make sure that you are receptive to
advice and you're going with kind of not a full cup. You're
making sure that the cup is half full or 3/4 full so that
they can give you some frameworks, some tips, and so forth.
And then don't come back to them until you've implemented to
some degree what they told you to implement. I think it's
very easy to say, "Oh yeah. Yeah, that's a great idea, but
it's not what we're doing" or something like that. And it's
disrespectful to then ask for help again, and ask for help
again if you're not actually implementing.
And so, what I try to do is just try to keep track of what
people are advising us to do and you know, if it makes sense
for us to try and so forth, you know, we'll do it. "Hey,
here's what we did." And it's a formula that worked really
well for us.
So, after awhile I had gotten to understand more of the BC
process. Still, you know, 100 hour weeks into the business
and just putting the sweat equity in and bootstrapping it.
And then, we decided that we needed for the business reason
to be better capitalized. And a lot of what drove that
decision was our ambition. We were seeing success in the
marketplace, but we had multiple verticals and therefore we
had multiple competitors. And we didn't want to have too
small of a balance sheet to go after.
And so, we decided to go through a formal process of picking
seven or eight VC's that we enjoyed meeting, that we knew,
and that we had some degree of a relationship with and we
went through the process. I don't know if you want me to go
through the nuances of that, but what ultimately resulted
was choosing among a few term sheets Greg and Josh to be our
partners and raise that capital.
And by that time there was a long - term relationship and
they met the tasks of know, like and trust. They understood
our business and we were able to do a deal that we felt was
win - win on both sides.
I mean, I think the thing that's symmetrical in that is that
longitudinal data really helps about people. So, they've
gotten to know us over a period of time. I think, you know,
you actually know the metrics guys for longer, right? But
that does really help.
And so, in the same way I think just developing those
relationships will give you confidence that you're working
with high quality people. But it will also give other people
confidence as they say, "Oh, well we talked about this last
time." So, the way I think about it is, "You told me you
were going to do x. Now you came back, did you do x or do
you have a good reason why you decided x wasn't the thing to
do, y was?" Right?
The one nuance I'll put on Matthew's point is I just always
want emerging CEO's to make the decision. This is not the
case necessarily with all board members or all venture
firms. I'm perfectly happy to be an idea machine, but the
last thing I want you to do is to go implement everything
that I say because that's a recipe for disaster, right?
I mean, ultimately the guy working 100 hour weeks knows more
about the business than anybody else in the world, right?
And has got to take all that data and meet at the place
where we can synthesize, and things are prioritized, and
makes the call about what to do and what not to do. And I'd
much rather have that conversation about, "What are the
three things you're going to do?" than "What are the 10
things you're not going to do?"
And they can change from time to time cause I assume that
you're out there learning and getting smarter every day.
And the things that we do enjoy about Greg and Josh, and I
continue to have a philosophy around is that venture
capitalists who have been in your shoes are better than
[inaudible] who haven't.
And so, people who have been in operating roles at companies
or have started companies, they understand and speak a
language that's easier for an entrepreneur to get really
insightful advice about the operations of the business on.
And that's been extremely helpful.
And the other piece that's been extremely helpful to have
these guys on is to continue to get introductions to people
and scale the team. So, when you think about the value add
of venture capitalists, it's expensive money in a
traditional sense. You want to mainly do it when it's the
right time for the business, but they will introduce you to
a lot of people or have those connections available if you
want to take advantage of those introductions. In our case
we did and that's been a huge source of referrals in terms
of people joining our company.
My philosophy is that basically there are four rules of
venture capital once you're an existing investor. The first
is physician do no harm, right? Don't try to run the
company. Don't medal where you don't have information. Make
sure that the CEO is running the company. The ultimate
responsibility of the board is hiring and firing CEO's.
And then there are three places where I think you can be
generally useful. One of which is strategic guidance in
pattern matching. I mean, I'm sitting on 10 boards, I've
probably sat on another 10 or 12. Over the history of time
you just see a lot. It is a job where you're a bit, you
know, a mile wide and an inch deep. You know, if you're
really good you're two inches deep rather than one. But I
think that does have something to do with pattern matching.
And the second is you know, you're a business development
arm of the company. And the third is you're a recruiting arm
of the company. And those are the three places where you can
really help. So, the four rules are don't' hurt, and help in
those three places and you're doing your job.
So, I want to flip over to Terry for a second because I
think this is a bit of , you know, a different story. Right?
On some level you'd say, "Well Terry is, you know, a
professional CEO - had been a CEO before, had been a COO
before that, you know, in very successful company." But I
think also came in and told the story that just because a
presentation is just telling a story, right? You're telling
it with 20 PowerPoint slides, but you're just telling a
story.
And so, this happened for me, I don't know. Probably 15, 16,
18 months ago and it just all clicked. You know, so 45
minutes of presentation and all those pieces work. Now, we
just want Terry to raise a very successful follow - up of
venture capital with a friend and regular co - investor of
mine. And another good guy who, you know, again, people
matter, right? My co - investors, they matter a lot, right?
But I think it'd be interesting for Terry to talk a bit
about how we frame that. We actually loaded up his
presentation on the computer here not for him to flip
through the whole thing, but I think there are some key
slides that are, you know, potentially good examples to say,
you know, "Your company's different, but you have to have
one that looks like this to solve this problem."
So, I don't know if you want to talk a little bit more about
[overlapping] first.
Let me give you a little context on the company and what
stages it went through when Greg invested. I'd probably add
a fifth to your list of things to help with and that is
fundraising in the next round, targeting, focusing, finding
the right fit because there are a lot of VC's out there. You
know, I'm not an expert on what VC's are and what they focus
on. But Greg is and was able to focus on really getting us
very focused in this round.
We raised $27 million to date. We just raised $11 million of
it. We announced it this week. We raised it a couple of
weeks ago. That's essentially our series "C". Greg invested
essentially our series "B" which is a harder round to invest
in because you kind of have to have a shared vision with the
investor about where the market's going. The way I
characterize it is in some ways "A" is easier because it's
all promise. If you believe the idea's big, and the market's
big, and the people are smart it's all promise. You don't
have any reality to bet on yet. So, you're betting on the
dream.
"B" has some reality and it's not all good. You know, the
company had a product that solved a problem. We had six or
seven customers, but hadn't added customers very quickly. We
didn't have a lot of repeatability. You know, so Greg had to
believe in enough of the vision of what we could do with the
proof points that we had, and had to believe in the team,
and you know, that we'd be able to execute on the
fundamental things that we needed to change to make business
really, really turn, and sort of have the patience to see
that through with you.
So you know, we found that with Greg and Sutter Hill.
And actually, can I make a...
Yeah.
couple of additional observations right now cause this is,
again sort of my framework as an outsider coming into the
business and what made that work because there's one other
thing about the company, right? Which is it went through its
series "A", but over two and a half or three years, I mean,
all with the foundational capital which is good for the
investor, right?
But God, you know, two and a half or three years, and $8
million, or $9 million, or $10 million is like it spent some
time looking for its future, trying to get chronic market
fit. You know, me I'm always trying to say, "When you walk
in the door do you have product market fit" is the
fundamental question and not, "Has it been a completely
linear path?" There are a lot of people who wouldn't want to
look at something that has been around for three years and
is just getting there. That doesn't bother me at all, right?
But then to this same point you say, "Well, what are the
access points that made it easy to make a couple of those
bets?" So, the first is Terry, right? So, the fact that the
story was so clear, and crisp, and well articulated, and
that when you periodically drilled down into something he
had good, thoughtful answers. Even if I didn't agree with
them necessarily they were thoughtful and well thought out.
There was a rationale behind them.
And you know, that really matters. The place where it's
hardest to do that honesty is in the financial model because
it's all assumptions, right? But even the notion that, "Hey,
you've been cleared by who your customer segment is, which
features they need, how you're pricing, what's tapped
market, and that it's all lined up and strategically
consistent", right? Basic stuff, but a lot of times it
doesn't show up.
But you know, the other thing about Terry is we have a very
close, mutual friend, right? A good personal friend of mine
who had worked closely with Terry in the last company. And
I'm telling you, it's an example of, you know, the weak
ties. It makes a difference because I'd call one guy and
say, "Just tell me the truth", right? And so, that makes a
big difference.
The second is this whole predicted analytics technology step
which nobody else is using in banking fraud prevention, but
a lot of people are using in internet monetization, and
[inaudible], you know, and the like. So, I was very familiar
with the technologies that even though it was being applied
in a totally different place and I had experts that I could
bring to say, you know, "Can you help me come kick the
tires?" And if it's a completely different technology staff
where I don't know the experts it's just that much harder to
get my arms around.
And the third is the target customer segment. My sister runs
one of these banks, right? And so, I mean I grew up knowing,
you know, for most people you say, "I'm selling to community
banks" and you're like, "Well, I do business with Wells
Fargo or B of A". I don't know any of those, right? I'm not
used to it. Venture bank companies aren't usually selling to
them.
So again, I come back to this notion of these little access
points demystified. So, when you're looking for, you know,
an investor it sometimes is worthwhile...
From the entrepreneur side going through that, and we talked
with a few firms to raise series "B". And series "B" was
hard to raise because we had been around for a few years and
you know, we had some reality but not a ton of proof on
where we were trying to take the company. And you know,
there were some VC's who went through really deep diligence
with us - painful, excruciating diligence. I didn't
necessarily feel like I had a lot of choices at the time,
but if I did feel like I had a lot of choices the fact that
they were taking me through such excruciating detailed
diligence would have been a sign that we were probably not
aligned.
Great due diligence. It wasn't painful. He asked for
information, but he had a lot of touch points already and he
had a lot of confidence in the technology stack, and the
market, and the viability of it. And he wanted to vet the
things that he should vet. So, you didn't feel like you were
re - explaining the rationale behind the business every time
you interacted with him. In some cases, you know, that's a
sign. If you keep explaining the same things to your
potential investor and they keep asking the same questions
over and over that's not alignment. You know, that's not
good alignment. They may think it's a great idea, and want
to invest, and want to believe, but you really need - I
think everybody's said - the cultural fit, chemistry and
alignment are probably the most important thing in getting
this to work because you don't work together through thick
and thin.
And your business plan is not going to be what happens. Your
business plan is a spreadsheet and a set of projections
based on your best information right now. And things are
going to change. You have to know why. You have to be
thoughtful about why and you have to be thoughtful about
what to do next when things do change. And you know, you can
come in under your plan, you can come in over your plan, but
I guarantee you you're not going to come in exactly at the
plan you put down when you go talk to an investor about
funding the business.
And we've done both. We've done both together and when you
know you have alignment is when, you know, the quarterly
results didn't come out the way you expected and you're
lower. And the reaction is, "Well, let's understand the
fundamentals. What's going on? What's your assessment of
why? And are the basic premise of how we're building the
business are that the customer's still buying it, that the
market is still receptive, that your product plan is still
tracking, are all those still in place? Okay. Let's go
forward."
And in fact, I can remember one quarterly meeting after Greg
had invested where the management team was so sort of
distressed at not having made their numbers that Greg and
the other investors were actually being the cheerleaders in
the board meeting explaining to our management team that, "
Hey, everything you're doing is pushing the rock up the hill
and things are going to get better because you're executing
on all the fundamentals that we all believe in."
So, it wasn't about this kind of maniacal focus on, "Why did
you miss this number?" "Why didn't you get this deal closed?
" It was on the fundamentals and the metrics of the business
and that's real alignment. That's real alignment on why you'
re doing it. And you know, I think it's been a great
partnership from that standpoint.
Series "C" is actually what we just raised is a different
round. You know, we were able to - with our series "B" money
- execute a lot of things that we wanted to execute. We were
able to transition the business to a Sass model, we were
able to restructure our pricing and our go to market
approach, we were able to develop some channel partnerships
that are starting to pay off, and we're able to get a level
of repeatability in the sales model that, you know, is still
not going to be perfect and is not going to trend exactly
how we think . But we're able to competently say, "Look, we'
ve got a couple of quarters under our belt where we said we
were going to sign this many customers, we did. We're
deploying quickly, we transitioned to the Sass model and it'
s working." So, we've got a lot of vectors that are working.
There are still a lot of uncertainties, but it's more. You
know, I think of series "C" as you've hit a pace where you'
re repeatable and somewhat predictable, and you want to pour
some fuel on the fire and grow on that predictability and
repeatability.
So actually, one of the things that I want to do in two
different ways with these two different companies is
actually pull on this thread of what I'll call transitioning
the business and you know, when you decide to do it, how you
do it, and what the risks are of doing it. And I think in
the Inflection case it's launching new product categories,
right?
And so, I think one of the guys who I have tremendous
respect for is Ben Horowitz who's Mark Andreessen's partner
at Andreesen-Horowitz. Ben and I were product managers
together at Netscape earlier in my career. And he's one of
the guys that I look at and say, "Oh, he's doing the same
job I am, but he's just much better at it."
But you know to me, interestingly, I would say, you know,
that's how you learn, right? I mean, babies learn because
they mimic the adults and the older kids in their
environment. And I think, you know, the life lesson is you
surround yourself with great people, and you learn what
they're doing, and you mimic it. And I have this theory
coming out of business school that I had just learned by
running my own experiments and learning faster. Turns out
that's a much slower way to learn and it's a lot easier just
to go to great companies with great people and learn from
what they do. You'll make plenty of your own mistakes along
the way.
But you know, one of the things Ben said, "when he was
running Opsware was basically launching a new product -
version 1.0 of a product is the single hardest thing you do.
" You know, I have many product managers or engineering
leads who can do version 2, and 3, and 4. When there's a
bunch of data and customers to talk to version 1.0 is
brutal. And there are only four or five people in the
company who I trust to do that, who got enough intuition
about product/market fit. And if I don't have one of those
people available I won't let a project start. Either I'm not
going to do it or I'll buy it.
And so I think, you know, if you maybe want to talk about
launching, you know, any new products cause I think that is
part of what opened up the business, opened up the available
market for the company and put it on a bigger stage.
Yeah. How many people here are interested in launching a
consumer facing type of product? Just so I can get a sense
of consumer internet.
[inaudible]. B2B? No? Okay.
So for us, I mean launching a product's really tough. The #1
set of lessons I got was by doing it to feed myself. When I
was in college I had no money. I was working for $6 an hour
at some work study program, was going to school and I was
trying to figure out how to sell eBooks to high school
students on how to get into college. And so, I was writing
sales letters, and creating marketing material, and trying
to convince people to do it, and do it over the phone. And
that actually was the best single learning experience
because when you're at that stage you quickly get the
lessons. It's much better than reading it out of some book.
But you know, taking it up a level I think that you want to
be data driven, you want to be quantitative. Greg talked
about that. It's one of our core values at our company. We'
re constantly looking for folks who are analytical and who
are thinking. We call it not intellectual honesty. We call
it thinking clearly reflection. "Are they a clear thinker?"
is one of our benchmark kind of questions on interviews.
And so, you want to be listening to the data because we all
have ideas. Ideas are a dime a dozen and we all can have
intuition about what's going to work but at the end of the
day, users will surprise you no matter what. And what we've
created, you know, it's still continuing to morph and form
at Inflection. But we've created essentially a loop where
kind of a product manager, someone who's the quarterback of
the product you're going to launch or the feature. It could
be either. And then you have Engineering who's going to
build it, you have Design who's going to design it and
preferably the wire frames, mockups, everything else. And
then you have an analyst who is going to continue to
research the data, understand what it's saying and report
back.
And that feedback loop with some QA involved and a few other
functions is really kind of the magic formula for us. We've
launched a ton of websites, and features, and products at
Inflection. And what we've tried to do is along the way look
at the patterns for us of what are emerging and then put
those into the platform so that we can continue to be faster
at launching things.
I will say that the most successful launches we've done have
always been, you know, the three weeks before that no one
slept hardly at all. Everyone was up all hours of the night.
There are always millions of more details to make these
things work than you ever expect going in. There is no
replacement for just hard work, rolling up your sleeves and
getting it done. And I think that you need to be working
with people that, you know, you can go to war with in that
regard.
I remember, you know, myself and one engineer being at the
office at all hours of the night one time when we were
launching a website and just looking over and thinking, "If
I just didn't inherently trust this person, if we weren't
totally on the same page this would have never worked. We
could have never gotten this far." And companies are so
bureaucratic once they start growing just by nature of
adding a lot of people to the company that I definitely
would never underestimate the value of, you know, whoever
you're working on with that initial product launch. You've
just got to make sure you guys are on the same page and the
same wavelength.
So Archives.com, you know, basically has become, you know,
half the business or something, right? And you know, it's a
two year old product, right? So, it was launched two years
into history. Was it, you know, one more website among many
that you'd launched when you guys decided to do it? Or did
you know it was a big deal and therefore it was launched
with more forethought?
Yeah, it's a combination of all things, but you know, just
the metaphors we use - throw the spaghetti against the wall
and see if it sticks. We use an agile development cycle. So,
oftentimes we're throwing things against the wall and if
they start gaining traction we add more resources to it. If
they really look exciting or promising then we really dig
in. We may throw away everything that we've already done to
date because we think it's such an opportunity that we need
to build it, you know, in a more substantial way.
But one of the things that an entrepreneur friend of mine
told me that's really stuck with me is don't weigh
opportunities equally. You'll see so many opportunities in
your business for improvement it's easy to lose sight of the
fact that, you know, some opportunities are, you know, 50
times more important than others. You know, hire a really
phenomenal VP of Engineering vs. you know, fixing the code
on that one site or optimizing the checkout process,
something like that. They just can't be weighted equally.
They can't make it to your to do list equally. They can't
consume your mindshare equally.
So, for us, we saw that, "Hey, there's this baby boomer
demographic shift that's happening in the United States. We'
re acquiring all this historical data and it doesn't look
like a lot of people are actually acquiring and organizing -
and everything from census records, to newspapers, to
obituaries, to death records internationally. And we see
that people online are very interested in genealogy.
Meanwhile, the leading company in the space - Ancestry.com -
has a product that's over $200 a year which doesn't really
appeal to a beginning person who's interested in their
family history.
Their S1 provided the data including the fact that 15% of
folks in the United States express an interest in family
history. That's kind of interesting. And we started putting
all these pieces together and said, "You know what? This
makes sense."
So, the first site we launched was called GeneologyArchives.
com and it was doing amazingly well right from the get go,
and it had a lot of head room. So, we went out and found the
person that owned Archives.com. They weren't using it. We
made a big bet because we didn't have easy money and that
was an expensive acquisition. But we made a big bet from
retaining the earnings, put the bet on the table and we're
now the #2 family history website. Our product's $40 a year
for unlimited access. We're growing very rapidly in that
category and it's got a lot of growing room ahead. So, I
think that's kind of a story of how we did it.
You know, I think from there I would just love to maybe ask
Q & A when we get to Q & A of what other nuances we can go
into.
Yeah. I mean, the thing I think is interesting about
consumer nano products is there's so much feedback and
there's so much data. So you know, product management - the
product market big piece is always some part analytical and
some part creative. And the creative part is, "What do you
put out there to test?" Right?
So, if you don't have some bit of that creative instinct or
judgment about what people might want, then you can put a
bunch of things out and they'll all fail. If you get the
right kind of people to make those judgments - hopefully
often the founder, right, or one of the founders - then you
can start analyzing data and figure that out.
You know, I think the other half of the transformation piece
- and this is one of the bets I was willing to make at
Guardian. I think maybe some other people weren't and that
has gone exceptionally well but is really, really hard is -
in service of trying to create better business is this
transformation to Sass. So, from an enterprise software
customer deploys in their own environment on their own
hardware...
Yeah.
to a Sass based solution. And I wonder if you could talk a
little bit about both what that was like to actually do, but
also how transformative it's been to the business model.
Yeah. It's been huge and you know, it wasn't a technology
decision. It was a strategy decision and it was a marketing
decision to begin with. And I'll give you a little of that
context.
The company started out like most security companies in the
Financial Services space saying, "We've got to get Bank of
America, and Citibank, and Wells Fargo. And you know, that's
going to validate the product and put us on the map." And
they tried that. We tried it for a couple of years before I
got there, but we tried it for a couple of years.
I think the biggest banks we succeeded getting were Zion - a
pretty good sized bank, First Republic, Silicon Valley Bank,
you know, decent sized banks but not he really big guys.
And then we were starting to have some success with smaller
banks - regional community banks. But we were this on prem
model. And you know, they had to deploy it, they had to buy
a server, they had to start an IT project. We had to go on
site, we had to stand up the system, we had to integrate to
all the different databases and operating systems that big
IT shops have. Inevitably with the bigger banks we ran into
the, "Well, let's just tweak this and customize that, fit it
into our environment this way". So, every job was kind of
this big, massive effort to get it working.
And we looked at the market and said, "Well look, there's
17,000 or so banks in the U.S. Thirty of them are really big
and look like Bank of America and Wells Fargo and the other
16,970 don't. And most of those guys actually buy their
online banking system from one of about 10 providers. There'
s Intuit, there's Buy Serv, there's Fidelity, there's Jack
Henry and a handful of others.
So, the market's actually consolidated around these internet
banking platforms and these banks buy outsourced services
because they buy their internet banking platform from a
essentially Sass provider. I don't think they called it Sass
when they first introduced those things. And they buy
solutions. They don't want to buy something and rip it apart
and reconfigure it to fit into their custom environment. And
they make decisions. And oh by the way, they're also
completely under protected from fraud. And the fraudsters
have figured it out and started attacking them. So, the
problems have merely migrated from the big banks down to
these small guys.
So we said, "That's who we should go after. That's really
who's going to buy our product." But to do it we have to
have a Sass solution. For all the kind of cost and
complexity issues, but also that's the thing that this
market needs. So, we decided to make that transition. It was
not an easy decision to make. We put a lot of thought into
it and we had to raise money. And we added this to that and
said, "Well, we've decided this for these reasons and we
know we can execute and make this transition to Sass." And
that's kind of a scary prospect because companies try to
make a transition from
[inaudible] to Sass and it's not always easy.
We were lucky in a couple of ways -
We didn't have to change our business model. We charged a
subscription for our software from the beginning. So, even
though it was deployed on prem we didn't have to change the
way people paid for it.
We knew that this was going to be hard, so we anticipated
it. We hired a really extraordinary
[inaudible] person who I happened to know through previous
companies. He worked with me at Good Technology and his boss
worked with me at Good Technology, and at Market Live. So, I
knew him. I knew he had a pedigree and could set it up. He
could do it and he was willing to really put the effort in
to do it from scratch. And we know we're dealing with
personally identifiable information about account holders in
banks in our hosting center and we're a venture back
startup. So, we knew security might come up in the
conversation.
So you know, we anticipated that from the get go and we went
and talked to these banking platform providers and to our
existing customers and said, "Give us your security audits.
If we came to you with a hosted solution, what is the
security audit that you would put us through?"
And we got a half a dozen of these security audits and we
also got an outside consulting firm that does security
audits for banks. And we designed our Sass solution based on
those security audits. So, we're Sass 70 level 2 compliant,
all those things. We also have a dozen security audit check
lists from real banks in our file drawer that we checked off
as we were designing and building the Sass solution.
So, when we migrated, and we've gone out, and we started
selling and they said, "Well, how do you pass the security
audit?" They pull out there's. Well, we've got as part of
the Vin diagram we've already solved for all those things
and we haven't had a single issue. We haven't not gotten a
single deal because of security concerns which is one of the
things that kept me up at night for nine months while we
made the transition to Sass.
So, it was very successful. And by the time we actually
turned the switch on the Sass solution - it was just this
past August - I think we had 17 customers on
[inaudible] and all but three have said definitively that
they're going to migrate to the Sass solution. So, that's
pretty good. And we've added 25 or so new customers to the
Sass solution.
So, talk about things like, you know, deploying timeframes
to value...
Yeah.
sales cycles and the like cause I think this is part of the
benefit of the Sass business model...
Yeah.
that has just been proven now today.
Well, it's massive. You know, deployments from
[inaudible] customers took 4 - 5 months. The actual work was
less, but the elapsed time to get them to set up the IT
environments, secure the servers, get everything set up,
they had to launch an IT project, and then we had to do a
bunch of on premise stuff. It took about four or five
months. We're doing deployments on platforms that we know in
2 - 3 days now - literally from months to days.
The 17 customers we had were all on a different version of
the code on
[inaudible]. All of our Sass customers are on exactly the
same code base and we do a weekly release. We do a weekly
[inaudible] fix and feature update release every week. Every
Thursday there's a release meeting where we push a new stack
of code out every Friday every customer's on the same code
base.
And then fraud prevention, that's a big deal because the
criminals are changing all the time. And we have a customer
right now that we're trying to save that's still on
[inaudible] who's on like four
[inaudible] back because they haven't gone through the
hassle of updating and they said, "You know, you're not
stopping all the fraud." And we're like, "Well, 4.2 does.
That exact fraud case we stopped last week at another bank
on 4.2. But you're on 3.0. We can't protect you with today's
fraud with yesterday's code stack."
So, having the Sass solution has been kind of revolutionary.
And you know, there's an upfront fix cost, but every
incremental customer that we add to the Sass solution, the
marginal cost of that customer is very, very small. So, we
can grow to a couple of hundred customers without really
adding any significant fix costs for the business. And it
becomes a very, very capital efficient model.
[Informal Talk] Great. Well, I think we've hit 2:45. So,
thanks for your time and attention. And we'll hang around if
you have any more questions after the panel. Thanks very
much.